- [Joanna] Laptops, water, devastation.
(dramatic music)
Now, if you were the
owner of one of these,
you'd probably first cry
and then you'd immediately
go to the Apple store.
And that's exactly what
Apple wants you to do.
The company and many others
restricts how and where
you can repair your stuff
in a variety of ways.
Apple says this is to make
sure customers receive
safe and reliable repair services.
But now some elected
officials and lawmakers
wanna give you more choices,
what's generally called
the right to repair.
This doesn't mean you have
to go all Rosie the Riveter
with your own tools.
This is also about making
it much easier for others,
including independent repair
shops to help fix your stuff.
That doesn't look good.
- This doesn't look good
at all and it's corroded.
The worst part is over here.
- Oh boy.
The Fair Repair Act,
which was introduced in Congress in June
would require original
equipment manufacturers
to make available certain documentation,
diagnostic and repair information
to independent providers.
Over 20 states have introduced
similarly worded bills,
none have been enacted yet.
So what does this all mean,
and would this really help you,
the hopeless person with a broken gadget?
Yes, it probably would.
Certainly my journey to
repair two very dead Macooks
showed it could save
you both time and money.
Let's first talk about these two machines.
This is a 13 inch 2017 MacBook Pro,
which at the time cost $1,400.
The second, a 2020 MacBook
Air that cost $1,100.
Both I grabbed from my IT department
and were marked as having water damage.
I promise you I did not
actually spill water on these
to break them.
So I packed them up and
went to the Apple store.
Since they were out of warranty,
and I don't have AppleCare Plus,
which covers accidental damage.
I walked out of the store, pretty sad,
799 to fix the Air,
999 to fix the Pro.
And the genius I spoke
to basically suggested
I just buy some new machines instead.
Shocker.
Then Mike's Tech Shop,
an authorized Apple service
provider had even worse news.
It sends the laptops
out to Apple to be fixed
and it adds its own labor charge,
$870 for the Air, 1,170 for the Pro.
Yeah, Nope.
Plus both of those
stores said it would take
five to seven days for the repair.
That's when I decided to go to a shop
that doesn't have any
relationship with Apple,
such as Rossman Repair.
The owner, Louis Rossman
has been an advocate
about the right to repair.
- The only option is to go to Apple
and to have this three or $4,000 device
fixed by them for 1500 dollars.
- [Joanna] He's also got
a popular YouTube channel
where he often criticizes
Apple's repair restrictions,
champions the right to repair
and shares his opinion on various topics.
- It's really important
to me with right to repair
that what we're asking
for, be very reasonable.
- [Joanna] His price
quote, $325 for the Pro,
but a no go on the Air
because he didn't have
the parts or information.
Another independent
repair store in New York,
very similar pricing.
So let's think about this for a second,
999 at Apple or 325 at Rossman Repair.
I think it's pretty simple.
An Apple spokesman said,
we believe the safest
and most reliable repair
is one handled by a trained technician
using Apple genuine parts,
and we continue to
expand Apple's offerings
to better meet our customer's needs.
He added that Apple would
replace the entire motherboard
for a repair like this, which
makes it more expensive.
But to really understand
how this legislation
wants to change things,
I had to see what was happening
inside these machines.
Here's the first one, it's
a 13 inch MacBook Pro.
- The big deal is that
corrosion that is over here
is right next to where
the WiFi data line is.
- Translation, the water cause
corrosion on the motherboard.
And it's around components
that help with, oh, you know,
just three little things,
power, Wi-Fi and your screen,
but Rossman still thought it had a chance.
- So let's see if this one
has a chance of working
because it doesn't look like
the corrosion around that area
is too bad.
It is gonna, this is
like filing your nails.
- That's not what filing
my nails looks like.
Now, two things really made this repair
possible for Rossman.
One, he had the extra parts to
swap in for the broken parts.
He got them from what
are called donor boards,
boards from old systems
with still usable parts.
Two, he had schematics and board views.
These are basically maps
of what's in the system
so he can figure out what is what,
except these documents
created by the manufacturer
aren't provided to
independent repair shops.
Rossman and others get these documents,
which are often leaked from
people that work at the company
from sites on the internet.
That's part of what the right
to repair wants to change.
So Apple doesn't give you any of these.
- No, and I can't get access to it
as a third party repair center.
And if you become an
authorized repair center,
you still can't get access
to any of this stuff.
- And was this originally
an Apple document?
Is this like something Apple put together?
- Yeah, it says right in the bottom of it,
it says over here, notice
of proprietary property,
this information contained herein
is the proprietary property
of apple Apple Inc.
- An Apple spokesperson
said that the company
has an independent
repair provider program,
which provides access
to Apple genuine parts,
tools, training, service
guides, diagnostics,
and resources to perform
a variety of out of warranty repairs.
He added that the company has found
individual chip replacements
to be unreliable,
which is why it replaces
the full motherboard.
However Rossman and others
say that this Apple program
does not provide schematics or board views
and many specific parts
that make repairs more
affordable for consumers.
After about 15 minutes of work,
we were ready to see if it had been fixed.
It's on.
- It is on and it's charging.
- Okay, that was the MacBook Pro.
But what about that MacBook Air?
- No.
- Rossman have access to
the board view document
for that specific MacBook Air,
which meant it was a no-go.
- This one, even if I did
have all the information,
you know, it doesn't really
have the highest chance
of being repairable,
but when you combine the
factor that it looks like this
with the fact that I don't
have all the information
I need to do my job, I
would say, screw this.
- Why don't you have the
information to do your job?
- Because I can't find the board view
because it's not available.
I have to wait for someone at Apple
or one of these factories
to leak that board view
and risk their job or
risk them being in prison
to one of those websites
so that I can then buy it.
- He also said that getting
the parts to fix the Air
aren't available yet to him.
So to recap, this 13 inch
MacBook Pro works perfectly now.
I even wrote this script on it
and I've been working on it.
This MacBook Air,
well, my only choice is
really to go back to Apple
and pay them 799 to fix it,
or I can buy a completely
new MacBook Air for 999,
which really doesn't seem
like a choice at all.
And that's what the right
to repair is all about.
Giving us more choices
to repair our stuff.
Tech companies and
opponents of the legislation
argue that that choice
can impact product safety
and data security and put companies'
intellectual property at risk.
What do you want to see the
most out of this legislation?
- I'd like to see it have the teeth
to be able to do the bare minimum,
which is get us access to
schematics, to board views,
and to be able to buy these chips.
It's odd to be a computer repairman
and feel like the kid in high school
that was selling weed
out of the fourth stall
of the lunch bathroom.
- The future of all this now
rests in the hands of lawmakers
or in this case,
maybe it should be in the
hands of laptop makers
who should consider liquid proofing.
- You can tell when
cats hate their owners,
based on the fact that they
piss on their computers.